[Music]
in recent years cambodia an
agriculture-based economy has seen
worsening impacts of climate change
including intense rainfall high
temperatures and sea levels rise
prevent province for example was hit by
both floods and droughts in 2018
resulting in losses and damage of up to
16 million dollars
the livelihoods of farmers are
especially affected
because
the asian development bank with support
from the pilot program for climate
resilience of climate investment funds
assisted the royal government of
cambodia to prepare the strategic
programme for climate resilience
consisting of seven investment projects
and one technical assistance project to
provide overarching support for the
seven investment projects two investment
projects relate to the agricultural
sector including the climate resilience
rice commercialization sector
development project this project is
helping farmers increase rice production
in three largest rice producing
provinces battambang kampong tom and
pre-venge by rehabilitating and
climate-proofing irrigation systems and
other rural infrastructure
specific engineering measures were
integrated into the design of
infrastructure to cope with more rapid
flows of
[Music]
the project also demonstrates the
benefits from laser land leveling to
conserve water and improve irrigation
water use efficiency
to assist farmers in reducing the
climate risks associated with rice
production the project is pilot testing
a weather indexed crop insurance scheme
in selected areas
the project is also improving the
availability and quality of rice seed by
developing a certification system that
will result in a more resilient crop
the project also helps create more jobs
for women all in all the project
contributes to economic social and
environmental sustainability of rice
farming in cambodia
you